wir befinden uns hier in einer
beliebigen bank irgendwo in keine ahnung
sagen wir mal
ja dieser wirksamer zu machen mißbach
alle ähnlichkeiten mit lebenden oder
toten personen wiesen sketch wären rein
zufällig oder nicht verzichten daran hat
der herr ulrich wartet schon 35 minuten
und wird langsam hatte bin ich gespannt
wie die wüste in zwei stunden ist weil
es erst einmal mit guten tag ja das
morgen einfach re group bekommt der
dinge ulrich mein name des energie- und
los geht's ich hatte das ja im
schriftverkehr gewissermaßen schon
erwähnt ich und mein geschäftspartner
wir haben eine sensationelle
geschäftsidee das ist ein ökologischer
müll von esther und wenn man den richtig
anwendet dann könnte man quasi die
komplette verschmutzung der weltmeere
beenden also das würde bedeuten dass wir
haben moment also das würde bedeuten
dass man mit hilfe von deutscher
ingenieur nennt die scanner sie nicht
wissen weil sie aus einem fernen land zu
uns gekommen sind
aber wie in bayern wir lassen uns
gegenseitig ahauserin verstehst mich ja
wohl ja und wie hier ist kein scherz ist
oder nicht
also ein kredit an kredit früher da war
und wir wählen was für die höhe
also wir würden natürlich stehen
anfangen und zur entwicklung von so
einem prototypen
wir bräuchten waren circa 200.000 euro
200.000 euro warum sonst in disney kleid
ist er überhaupt kein problem
der muss ja bloß mein geld schulden sind
übergroß wieder kleine scheine dann
nehme ich die großen indoor die großen
das ist eine gute entscheidung so europa
ist sich cody hodgson mach mir den rc
ich muss sagen ich verstehe sie nicht
stand 10 1 sowie allerdings auch mit
200.000 euro geht es bald drin das soli
ausgang oder was
jetzt sollen noch bayern weil nur um sie
aber was ein guter mann ich möchte
bemerken dass sich nunmehr seit über 17
jahren in miesbach auf sanchez ich bin
also ich würde das sehr begrüßen wenn
sie begrüßen da der dieses
begrüßungsgeldes oberhaus schien es dem
herrn pressiert wollen wir zu gehen das
ist eine bodenlose frechheit und das
machen sie nur weil ich sachse bringen
dabei hört man das sogar nie
ach so sie songs rock sie jetzt mit
servus
ich glaube das mit der mauer oder fehler
aber ein riesenfehler du sagst du was
andere frage gehen die getränke für eine
große geburtstagsfeier sahen die show
alle geordert historische worden
freilich champagner vom allerfeinsten
wie immer champagner vom allerfeinsten
art und romy programm steht ja schon
alles da blaskapelle schuhplattler
goaßlschnalzer das volle programm um ein
geburtstags ansprache wird dann
wahrscheinlich der rucksack stets nur
billiger meine geburtsurkunde
ministerpräsident mappus und gas gibt
grossen schweizer schuhplattler du dann
muss die dinge auskomme die bdp noch
auto beschossen
die wohl wie so eine fischer ja auch
irene fischer muss kummer und die muss
dann happy birthday singen aber ich das
so ja so mehrerer mena so ungefähr
die besteller sparkassendirektor fichten
dran wie besteht ja schon ungefähr
[Applaus]
lehnen sie sich diese leisten
johannesburg hast was die sorge wie man
wird nur einmal im leben 59 kunden vor
allem streichung so fragt das nicht geht
diese ist gut
ja und jetzt schauen wir mal 14 uhr wird
eine sammlung zum verein und gegen
baumgarten aus wien wir noch da
baumgartner aus wien reicht die zeit
überhaupt nimmer opa wurde noch klicken
recht herr baumgartner bitte treten sie
ein system frühling schon leid über die
westautobahn war komplett verstopft
[Gelächter]
um was geht es denn dass wir nicht mehr
die vorzimmerdame qualifikationen ohne
respekt der kommerzialrat sie haben
einen stil
naja man tut was man kann aber jetzt und
hier baumgartner und wo es geht mir
nicht lange um den heißen brei herum
die brauchen pulver fast atmos geht ich
habe da verschiedene geschäfte mit depot
lagen und mit duschen am laufen und und
und und um wurst geht geht's du genau
sagen wir mal so ich habe mehrere häuser
also mit nadeln alle volljährigen aber
die kunden standards die werden immer
höher und die schönsten mädels die
kommen mittlerweile aus russland und zur
beschaffung selbiger bräuchte man sagen
wir mal circa 200.000 200.000 euro
das ist natürlich ein ganz schöner
batzen ja da werden wir nicht
umhinkommen geklappt da muss man einfach
gerne die betriebe der branche
[Gelächter]
der fichtenstraße ich glaube ich
verstehe sie ganz genau sagen wir mal so
wir uns auf eine hübsche kreditsumme
einigen könnten dann garantiere ich
ihnen leben lang freien eintritt in
jedes meiner etablissements und dann
kennen sie sich ihre investitionen
einmal genau anschauen also das nehme
ich einen großartigen business plan
wunderbar so immer die papiere fertig
sie unterschreiben dann steht der ost
erweiterung nichts mehr im wege
liechtensteiner rossi war
ist die hand fräulein schon sie wollen
sie nicht zufällig einmal bei schilling
dazuverdienen
das glaube ich kannst du dir nicht
leisten empfehlung schon etwas abstand
ich habe glaube ich gut einen
großartigen geschäftsabschluss getätigt
und in diesem zuge musst du dir kleine
geschäftsreise nach österreich machen
sozusagen betriebsbesichtigung verstehen
uns als mich niemand sagen ganz kleinen
kreis vor stadträten immer mit und einen
vorsitzenden vom schützenverein sowieso
und wollten aus gaudi die norderstedter
vor grünen der so gar nicht lustig aber
jetzt hat nix wir hinaus jetzt machen
wir feiern die heiland rad schwingt mehr
wer noch da sie grantig aus spinnst du
hast an land warten ja schaukasten re
bringst du da bist
es war sehr wusste wirklich deine
freiheit geht es gut hoffe ich alles gut
weil also mäßig kriterien die opfer
wieder im kasten braucht was von den
maya dunklen als sowas kurzfristig rana
es geht um als kredit du bist ein
kritiker freilich 200.000 euro 300.000
euro her kumpel nicht weit man bei
400.000 news es ist wenig rallyes wenig
ist ja nimmer auf 500.000 600.000 du
musst ein gefühl das gerüst noch etwas
übrig million ja wohl nochmal million
bisher kein thema mehr waren wo ist das
mitnehmen nachrichten ein
herrschaftszeiten warum italien ist
weiter ein scheiß ferrari vor meiner
einfahrt parkt
niklas den abschlägen rosso-ferrari
hannover manager thorsten storm kritik
mit oder ja auch gern ohne zinsen gay
bronze
manchmal million rund einer million für
für nun sicherheitshalber morgen in
nidda zu janet der herr landrat nicht
mehr um was zum feiern bringen
champagner
[Musik]